you might expect this massive storm is
also bad news for air Travelers today is
expected to be the second busiest travel
day around Christmas and New Year's
already more than 3 100 flights in the
U.S have been canceled and more than 900
others are delayed Chris Van Cleave at
least is inside he's at Dulles
International Airport in Northern
Virginia Chris good morning what is the
latest
well good morning being inside is about
where the good news ends that
cancellation totaled more than 3 000
that's already higher than we saw all
day yesterday it is not going to be a
good day for travelers really across the
country you're seeing significant
cancellations in airports from Seattle
to Denver to Chicago Detroit New York
and Boston
from California to New York the Friday
before Christmas starts with thousands
of flights already canceled and millions
trying to get home including Alicia
Mitchell we were supposed to leave at 2
40 and our fight was pushed back to 804
and now our flight has been delayed for
an hour welcome to United have all
boarding passes out the storm brought
busy Chicago O'Hare to a virtual halt
because of wind snow and ice more than
560 flights were canceled there Thursday
I mean we're hopeful but in the back of
our both of our minds we're like I don't
know if we're going to make it out
tonight
the massive bomb Cyclone is causing
travel chaos Nationwide as it whips
across the Midwest into the Northeast
with frustrated Travelers in Denver I
think our plans are ruined as whiteout
conditions surrounded the airport
dumping nearly half a foot of snow on
the runways
and in Los Angeles even though the sun
is shining Travelers are still stuck at
the airport feeling the storm's effect
from thousands of miles away we'll see
how it goes It was supposed to fly into
Houston Jessica Fanning and her
boyfriend are visiting the States from
Australia they missed their connection
to Houston and are now heading straight
into an Arctic blast we're flying at
midnight from here to Chicago and then
we have a one-hour layover and then
we'll land in New Orleans tomorrow
morning at 9am
and even after the storm blows through
that bitter cold we've been talking
about really complicates how you operate
an airport so we're already seeing
cancellations popping up for the weekend
Gail
oh boy here we go Chris this is one of
those days if you just have a two hour
delay you're grateful thank you thank
you very much